هذه مشاهد ليست من حرب اهليه ولا اشتباكات
بين متظاهرين والشرطه وانما هي مشاهد
تقليد غريب في مهرجان المطرقه المتفجره
السنوي في المكسيك
هذه البلده الصغيره تدعى
بمدينه غوانا اخواتو وسط المكسيك وتتميز
عن باقي المدن المكسيكيه بتنظيم تقليد
سنوي غريب وخطير وفريد من نوعه ومن اسمه
نستطيع فهم كيف سيبدو المهرجان
[موسيقى]
هذا الحشد الكبير يتجه من القريه الى ساحه
كبيره ستقام فيها مراسم المهرجان الذي
ينظم في شهر فبراير من كل عام لاحياء
تقاليد دينيه مرتبطه بعامل منجم اسمه
عاش في القريه وقال السكان المحليون انه
يشبه روبن هود حيث انه كان يسرق الذهب من
قطاع الطرق ويعيده لملاكه
الشباب من القريه يحملون معهم اكياسا من
المتفجرات محليه الصنع وتكون هذه
المتفجرات عباره عن مزيج من كلورات
البوتاسيوم والصوديوم المعباه باحكام ثم
يقومون بتثبيتها على راس مطرقه ثقيله
يدويه الصنع
ويحملونها على اكتافهم ويتجهون بها الى
وسط الساحه حيث توجد عوارض سكك حديديه ثم
يضربونها بكل ما اوتوا من قوه يحدث هذا
الانفجار الكبير
[موسيقى]
رغم اهميه المهرجان لدى سكان البلده
الصغيره الا انه محفوف بالمخاطر ولهذا
قامت السلطات المكسيكيه بوضع قوانين خاصه
في يوم الاحتفال وانشاء اماكن تفجير بعيده
عن المره للحفاظ على سلامتهم وتوفير
سيارات اسعاف في مكان المهرجان في حال
تعرض احد المشاركين الاصابات ورغم ذلك لا
يزال المهرجان يشكل خطرا كبيرا للغايه
بالنسبه للاشخاص الذين يشاركون فيه حيث
كشفت صحف مكسيكيه ان العشرات يتعرضون
لاصابات بليغه كل عام
ونصف
[موسيقى]